I want to like really emphasize to the
conservative audience that's listening
right now it's income it's incumbent
upon you guys to understand that it is
Federal Reserve policy that is making it
so challenging to have household
formation to get married to have kids
all of these things that you guys
consistently lament you miss the biggest
factor is that inflation has forced both
parents into the workforce and it has
made it incredibly and increasingly
challenging to be a parent to get
married to buy a home all of these
things are Federal Reserve policy uh you
know okay but that's only the government
can do this that's a large component of
it but cultural issues of course very
important too it's hand-in-hand I think
cultural is the bigger the central banks
they're all kind of controlling and
manipulating the media which is
manipulating the culture to because why
are people not more up in arms about the
Federal Reserve if they knew if you knew
that that private bank was disrupting
your life you would have taken it back
800 years ago if we did not ever have
the revolution in the workplace women
stayed at home it wouldn't matter what
the Federal Reserve tried to do